bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on parle du
nouveau au nom few 10
[Musique]
la ligue 2
elle est
fait
eh oui
un téléphone que j'ai dans la main j'ai
la chance de pouvoir essayer aujourd'hui
au cs à las vegas alors c'est vrai qu'on
aurait dit on en avait déjà parlé mais
là c'est cool pour le prendre dans la
mare leurs sacs déjà en termes de prise
en main je dois avocats l'un à dire il
se tient bien dans la main ça va c'est
agréable
pas de capteur d'empreintes digitales à
l'arrière pour le caméra arrière ici
vous savez le capteur qui situait juste
en bas ici
qui est plus tôt
pratique bon moi je n'ai pas paramétrer
donc
au moins il n'est pas paramétré mais ça
marche plutôt bien un téléphone qui
tourne avec un kirin 970 c'est vraiment
téléphone sans qu'elles honorent veut
aller avec l'intelligence artificielle
un smartphone qui va aller plus loin de
la reconnaissance de scène avec pas mal
de choses sont optimisés pour aller dans
ce sens là est justement ce processeur
kirin la 70 à permettre d'absorber grâce
à cette puissance l'apport absorber son
secteur quand tu calcules awa vous avez
un écran 5,99 course quasiment à ses
pouces on est sur du lcd
la qualité est franchement correct non
on n'est pas sûr du oled on va vraiment
la différence mais on n'est pas non plus
sur les prix due aux led donc il faut
pas tout confondre
mais c'est vrai que c'est un produit qui
est un très joli rendu et qui a vraiment
une très très belle qualité
les présenter la ans et gia drame c'est
un produit qu'on peut avoir en 64 giga
de stockage mais également en 128 gigue
en arrière vous avez une double caméra
une 20 mégapixels et une 16 mégapixels
côté batterie vous avez une 3750
milliampères heures plus de batterie
pour pouvoir après absorbé probablement
la puissance du processeur kirin 970
vous avez effectivement de la recharge
rapide permet de recharger à 50 % en
seulement 30 minutes c'est vrai que d'un
point de vue rendu en tenant dans la
main
c'est un produit que je trouve plutôt
agréable à ses fins bord légèrement
incurvé simple caméra l'avant double
caméra à l'arrière
bon après rien à leur reprocher il
faudra l'essayer davantage nos
conditions du réel
là je suis juste sur le stand on s'est
compliqué de se rendre compte la caméra
me semble correct nous semble à peu près
correct donc sensiblement les mêmes
caractéristiques techniques pour vous
trouver dans le produit de chez huawei
le mc 10 sauf effectivement là où sur un
creusement moins cher mais de très bonne
qualité à mon avis ce produit ils
estiment vraiment à ceux qui veulent pas
forcément investir plus par rapport à ce
qu'on pourrait trouver en terme de
produit chez huawei mais qu'ils veulent
quand même un premier d'excellente
qualité
donc je vous le recommande d'autant plus
que au nord c'est vraiment des très bons
produits
donc c'est un produit un avis qui ne
vous décevra pas dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est vous ce
honor view 10 pourrait vous intéresser
mark et moi tout ça on discute ensemble
je vais aussi vous présenter un autre
produit sioniste à côté de moi
le satis mais ça on en parle dans cette
vidéo vous dis à très bientôt
ça sonne ici il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit spationautes qui a parti avec un
téléphone merci beaucoup d'oranais la
vidéo à bientôt
sentez vous bien ciao
[Musique]